or évoquant toutes ces manifestations le
premier ministre qui se trouvait devant
le congrès de la ligue française de
l'enseignement à marly le roy a indiqué
que le gouvernement comprenait
l'inquiétude suscitée par le projet et
s'efforcer d'y répondre de façon juste
mais a ajouté qu'il ne tolérerait pas la
déviation de ses revendications lorsque
des difficultés ponctuelles surgissent
nous nous efforcerons toujours de les
surmonter par le dialogue et la
concertation
en revanche nous ne céderons pas à ceux
qui seraient tentés de transformer
l'expression de leurs revendications en
manifestation portant atteinte à l'ordre
public et à la sécurité des personnes et
des biens
je souhaite que chacun s'applique à
faire preuve de la même mesure et de la
même ouverture que le gouvernement pour
autant je demande aux étudiants de
prendre conscience du risque qu'ils
prennent lorsque leurs revendications
servent de prétexte à des groupes
d'extrême droite qui descendent dans la
rue pour y installer le désert est il
besoin d'ajouter devant vous avec les
souvenirs qui sont ceux de la ligue de
l'enseignement que ces groupes
extrémistes seront châtiés comme la
république sait le faire pour ceux qui
ne la respectent pas car mon roi qui a
par ailleurs confirmé que l'examen du
projet de réforme de l'enseignement
supérieur ne serait pas à repousser donc
ce sera le 24 mai à l'assemblée